it's delicious and but nobody likes the
taste of pot and if you say you do
you're lying and you stoned and open you
goddamn eyes have a drink
look we all like to unwind here and
there who's we
who says you can't have them both I'm
saying that you really should not have
them both I I do not recommend it
booze versus weed please party
responsibly it's debatable
my name is Maci and I love to get drunk
my name is Jessica and I smoke weed
every day I'm Kelsey I'm an alcoholic
I'm for a weed my name is Robyn and I
have fun when I'm drunk I'm Chris and
I'm 420 friendly being drunk is simply
way more fun than being high if there's
someone I'm intimidated by or I'm
attracted to I'm more likely to talk to
them and engage a conversation if I'm
drunk
champagne margaritas Moscow mules
there's none of that with a child
there's like an active naswinger drunk
you know like you love everybody and you
make friends and like pot doesn't make
you do that pot makes you go
should we go to you know almost all of
my best most favorite memories happened
when I was drunk
yeah you can get drunk anywhere was if
you want to smoke weed and get stoned
you kind of have to go to a private area
and hope you don't get interrupted you
can like go and do like a speech or
something like that they were really
nervous about do you do speeches drunk
I've seen you drunk and you're a fun
drunk
yeah just see me hi I guarantee you it's
been less on wine than you win on an
ounce of weed pot is so expensive oh
shut your mouth this is not even an
argument in today's day and age you
could probably get two grams for $25 and
that will like smoke you out for like
two weeks you and your friends drunk
Jessica I'd start texting people my
snapchats get all sloppy I start doing
the thing that every one girl does where
you do
with your drink why do I do that when
I'm stoned I'm very paranoid my concept
of time is completely skewed I don't
know if I'm making any sense so the last
time when I got high I laid in bed for
about seven hours convinced that I was
actually dead it was torturous at trust
me girl I have been there I've actually
called the cops and be like I think I'm
dying it was fine throw me
it's meditative it's calming and there's
a connection I think a lot of problems
will be solved the people just smoked a
joint and sat around a campfire and
talked about the world problems the
thing is is that you have the same
experiences when you're high oh when
you're yes no wait
nope when you are a marijuana smoker and
you meet another marijuana smoker there
is a hit off that happens that is like
no other you have to smoke weed out of a
joint you just smoke weed out of a pipe
you can do it out of a bong you can put
it in a brownie
since smoking weed I have stopped
wanting to drink soda drink any sort of
like artificial things I'm more into
like all-natural healthier things to put
into my body because you're a hippie now
it's about music it's about love it's
about like talking about bigger ideas we
mix you get to know who you are inside
I'm so confident that when I get high I
start thinking about [ __ ] that I
shouldn't be thinking about like what is
making my lungs go up and down right now
it's like bringing a bottle of wine but
in the 21st century you come in you you
you bring some but for everyone and
everyone enjoys each other's bud and and
and you're like mmm this is some great
quality but what did you boil I stop
something we threw out and I got high
for the first time and I had back then
it was like see I just didn't know what
was going on I was like how long am I
taking is it three hours or is it 30
seconds you felt like you were dying
there are people that actually die when
they drink a lot of alcohol weed is
better it doesn't cause you to die it
doesn't cause you to drive drunk you're
like nothing
stay here dude I don't think you go up
yeah I'll call cultures about love I
don't think that's the case
the reason bars sell alcohol is because
you have to be drunk to be around sweaty
horny strangers who are like ma'am I'm
gonna lick your feet and not call you
tomorrow what [ __ ] bars are you
do [ __ ] you talk to more people it's
like being on cocaine without actually
having to do cocaine I like to dance I
like hugs and I like to do it all but
I'm drunk I do all of those things stuff
I personally and the better more fun
person when I'm drunk it's not a city of
love but when you're high it will be
let Gino giant peach when you're high
and tell me